all right
[Music]
hey what's going on you guys hopefully
okay yeah I was like I was kind of
worried that the microphone wasn't
working there for a second I'm really
paranoid about it turning itself off all
the time because it does that but hey
it's Monday yeah that means it's a
haunting Mondays yep doing go Soldier
Tom Sykes says you guys pretty much
covered all the episodes on the distance
this episode is on I think we've mainly
covered most of the episodes from
season well for the first four seasons I
feel like at various times we've done
all of them this was one of the only
ones that remained yeah I don't like
this episode
yeah I was I'm not crazy about it it's
just a little bit
um like it's a cool like ghost story but
I don't know it's not all that
believable and it's just kind of like
not not a whole lot all of that
substance is yeah I guess mostly
feelings
and yeah it feels Fifi's it's just um
I don't know and and there's something
about the way that was edited I had a
hard time staying in the program
my mind kept wandering
I don't know why there's just something
about the way this one's edited well I
think the thing about it within what I
meant when oh shit's crashing all over
the place over there
um I think what I was saying when I
meant it wasn't all that substantive was
because you could tell that they didn't
have you know 48 minutes or whatever it
is like worth of content so a lot of it
is just kind of like filler you know
yeah yeah you got the synopsis though
right yeah okay well then I do uh and I
wanted to say because Hugo just arrived
Hugo is also our latest Patron oh no
Okay cool so just yeah I just saw the
message a little bit ago right yeah we
need so thank you very much yes we're so
we're all [ __ ] crying about it but
you know what I mean uh Tom Sykes said
the only good thing about this episode
was the evil spirit element that saved
the episode from completely sucking yeah
the thing about that though is that one
I don't know we'll like we'll get to it
but I'm just just as a teaser one what
the [ __ ] was that thing even supposed to
be uh that was the first thing and two
they never like explained what it was
like supposed like I don't know we'll
get into it because I was I was very
confused about that and it's hard to
classify this case what is this is this
a haunted is a haunted object maybe uh
they never really they never really give
you a good idea of what it was
of possession
I mean I'm guessing it's kind of like
supposed to just be a haunting you know
what I mean
but they well I mean okay
yeah but see I thought that the picture
was just like the Catalyst for the
actual ghost arriving yeah because the
thing about it is that they do kind of
like set this up the narrator at the
beginning by saying some people believe
because that's the way you can get away
with it by saying yeah some people
believe that every time you take
someone's photo like it steals a piece
of their soul like a little piece at a
time yeah you know they believe this on
the island of Borneo
or somewhere back in the 20s yeah
yeah I think it's like I don't think
anybody on Earth believes that anymore
no but uh but yeah but I'm sure there's
somebody there's somebody on Earth that
probably believes that that the photo is
stealing their soul but I think that's
kind of like the framework that they
were using like that they were coming at
this story from you know that's all I'm
saying I just don't know
like I said I don't like to cast
aspersions on anybody I was like the
ladies on here all seemed like really
nice people but I don't I just don't
know how much I'm buying this you know
and like you said a lot of it's like
really subjective yeah you'd have to be
there yeah
because I wouldn't believe it no no I
wouldn't either they did they only said
they saw a couple things move too and
there's things things falling I think
one in the picture fall off the floor or
something or yeah and then there was
kind of like some glass some wine
glasses went flying in yeah
which I think you weren't paying
attention
did they fall or were they fought you
had to be there it might have just fell
I just you know
I don't know
it was a weak case whatever it was
physically
not much happened yeah
Tom Sykes says you almost reviewed this
episode a while back on either yours or
Tom's birthday that fell on a haunting
Monday yeah I think that's what it was
we were thinking about it and then I was
just like no and then we decided to do a
different one instead but because part
of it we're like there's not a lot of
substance here they're not making much
claims well here's the weird thing I
could have sworn I must have been
thinking of a completely different
episode I could have sworn that this
episode like the picture in question I
thought that she bought it like at a
[ __ ] uh garage sale or some [ __ ] so
it was just some Rando but that's not
exactly how it happened so then I was
like sitting there thinking what the
[ __ ] was I thinking of then I don't know
what I was thinking of maybe that was an
episode of Paranormal Witness or maybe
that was like some other thing where
somebody found a picture of somebody at
a garage sale and then it like started
haunting them or some [ __ ] I don't know
because it because it wasn't it wasn't
this one it doesn't come to mind yeah I
mean she didn't know the guy personally
but he was like a he was like the
brother of her boyfriend or something
like that so he wasn't like a complete
stranger like I I don't know why I
thought she bought it at a garage sale
but you know uh let's see Tom Sykes says
the sis the sister actor was in the
episode titled the attic I thought I had
seen her in another episode that we had
maybe covered before because that
actress every time I see her in an
episode of this she looks almost exactly
like our friend Imani
because remember that lady I was like oh
it's like oh it looks like it's the
Imani lady again she does like look
eerily like her but yeah that was the
other one the attic that she was in
that's right I think we did cover that
one yet
um yeah you do like I said you do kind
of see like a lot of the same actors
turning up again and again
so uh so this story here now
interestingly they said what year it was
and they said with the people's names
were although the names are pretty
generic so I'm guessing it was their
real names because they weren't like in
[ __ ] uh Shadow or anything
interestingly they didn't say where this
took place now I did find somebody
mentioned this on like a Facebook group
about the about a haunting and this was
like many years ago and they said that
actually it took place in Vancouver
and that it actually didn't take place
in a house like they portrayed but it
was actually an apartment and then when
the family moved they actually moved to
somewhere in Washington state but they
didn't like mention for some reason they
didn't mention the location even though
they usually do on this show but they
didn't in this uh in this particular
case and I'm not really sure why that is
so I don't know if that's true but I
just found that on a Facebook group not
a lot about this particular case
although
somebody the same person on the Facebook
group said that the two girls the
daughters uh who were both on the show
like the real people that they were
actually pretty open about talking about
this experience like on various
paranormal forums and stuff although I
couldn't really find anything
about that but you know what I mean
uh actually lends some weight to it
because yeah I mean they were on there
people who could fake stuff don't want
to talk about it too much unless they're
getting paid
that's true yeah and in case they like
trip up and see something yeah it's a
paid performance and [ __ ] so
but yeah
so supposedly this took place in
Vancouver but I'm not entirely sure
that's just according to that Facebook
post or whatever
but they did say that it took place in
1994.
and the woman at the center of this who
was also the real person was interviewed
on the show
her name is Lisa Wilson
so 1994 she breaks up with her boyfriend
whose name was Dan I don't know how long
they've been together I don't think they
said
so apparently he'd been living there at
the house and he moves out
um I guess that they were parting on
good terms though it's not like you know
it was any kind of like acrimonious
anything
but uh Lisa has two daughters at the
time uh Laura was eight years old and
Sarah was 10 years old
so now she's like a single mom in living
in this house uh she's working full-time
they said she worked as an insurance
Clerk and she was also studying for her
college degree like a full full-time
student so she's real busy kind of broke
and you know kind of stressed out most
of the time you know as as that as
habits
so one night she's doing homework at the
desk in the living room like and it's
really late at night and she breaks a
pencil or some [ __ ] because it was 1994
so you still had to do everything by
hand
and she starts like pawing around at her
desk like looking for the sharpener I
guess
so in there she finds like this little
manila envelope
and inside it is a black and white
photograph that apparently her
ex-boyfriend Dan left behind in this
drawer
and it's a picture of Dan's Brother
Michael
now Dan's Brother Michael who she never
met was killed in Vietnam at the age of
19. just like that song that all our
castles are
um you know the old people will know
what I'm talking about so apparently
what happened to him was that he was on
a Recon Patrol and got ambushed and they
never found his body like I guess they
never recovered his body I don't know if
he got blown up or whatever but they did
find his dog tags and those got sent uh
back
so as I said Lisa had never met him
obviously because presumably like he was
already dead by the time her and Dan got
together
um now Lisa said that from the very
beginning of looking at this picture and
it's kind of a cool picture it's
obviously they didn't use the real one
but um because I saw the the actor that
was in the photo like he has an IMDb
page I can't remember what his name is
though so I thought well you know
they're actors that's you know they got
to work and he was kind of like moving
around in this one too like in some like
kind of flashback sequences so they had
him in that too so it's kind of like a
cool picture uh he's got sunglasses on
and everything and she said that
from the beginning like looking at this
photo
she said that he looked like he was
ready to die and I kind of wonder if you
would think that if you didn't know that
he was already dead right you know what
I'm saying that's just you know I'm just
I'm just making that observation yeah
um talk about the photo Jenny mentioned
the photo photo be an ex-military myself
and being from a recap to a first 3-7
Recon okay
um and and being a history buff [ __ ]
weapons and [ __ ] I instantly noticed
it's the wrong rifle well you know what
are you gonna do it's the wrong rifle
they just had to get the problem yeah
they had he's carrying it's the m16a2 it
would have been the A1 in Vietnam but uh
the big difference well no not big
visual difference different hand guards
different sites
um not quite as robust well I mean they
were both great rifles though I mean
like I said I'm not going to get to
because you know it's a haunting I'm
sure they don't have like a huge budget
to play with so they're just kind of
like whatever that looks whatever
they're like close enough whatever M16
just put it in the picture it's close
enough like I said it's like I see the
photograph I'm immediately taken to
1994.
oh man well yeah I mean that's when the
photo was taken probably
uh Tom Sykes says that evil spirit
looked like a nest of pubes at first
until I saw it was foliage wrapped
around a skeleton yeah I was kind I
thought it was like a like a burlap sack
with like bundles of branches sticking
out the end like besides like arms but I
just saw it for a second like and I
watched it I was like what the [ __ ] is
that supposed to be does it have a head
I don't know because I thought like I
don't know we'll get into it a little
bit later but I thought that like the
whole thing was It was supposed to be
another evil spirit like a person and
I'm like so why does it look like
something from like the [ __ ] wicker
man or something I don't get it I mean I
thought that they were gonna go into
like some kind of Mythology about it I
don't know it was really weird and the
thing is is she didn't
say that she saw something that looked
like that so I don't know why they would
necessarily why would they just get
another person like to come in and look
evil
I don't know I didn't get it
um but yeah so like I said she kind of
gets she was just very struck by this
picture like to start with and that the
photo just kind of like pulled her in
and she couldn't like stop thinking
about it
so that weekend after she finds the
picture Lisa's sister whose name is
Carol comes over now the real Carol was
also on there interviewed as well like
both the ladies were and then the
daughters were as well even though they
were older teenagers
um So Lisa shows her the photo and Carol
said pretty much the same thing she's
like yeah this photo was like just it
had something to it it just kind of like
Drew you in uh like the guy in the
picture was like trying to get your
attention or something uh the daughters
though they don't really seem to like it
they I guess they kind of thought it was
creepy or whatever
So Lisa decides that she's gonna have
this photo enlarged and all nicely
framed and everything and she's gonna
give it to Dan as a birthday present
because his birthday's coming up in a
few weeks so Carol thinks this is a
fantastic idea
So Lisa goes to the place and has it
done or whatever and she said it took a
week she gets excited about it when she
picks it up like she unwraps it when she
takes it home she's like I liked it so
much that I almost didn't want to give
it to him like she was just gonna
[ __ ] keep it you know what I mean uh
she said because at this point it
already become like such a big part of
her life
so she's like okay well I guess I have
to give it to Dan for you know it's a
birthday present I don't know but she
spent on it it's not cheap I'm sure
but she just like slid it under the bed
and like kept it under there
so apparently I'm assuming this was the
first night like after she picked it up
from The Print Shop she had I don't know
if it was a nightmare or if she saw this
in real life
but she kind of woke up it was actually
kind of like a good like creepy kind of
shot because she's like laying in the
bed and then like Michael kind of like
sits up in bed like behind her like hey
like what even with the sunglasses on
and I was like oh that's pretty creepy
like then one of the one of the best
scenes in in the episode yeah I don't
know if she felt a presence or if she
saw him you know I don't know see
because later on we'll get into that a
little bit too because later on she said
that she couldn't see him but the
daughters could see him yeah so I'm just
assuming that she had never seen him so
every time they showed him like in the
thing she was either dreaming about him
or she could just sense his presence
because I don't think she ever said that
she saw him specifically and like then
like later on she she basically said I
couldn't see him but the girls could see
him so we'll get into that too
so um so yeah so basically she's in bed
and like he sits up like that and she
just like jumps out of bed like what the
[ __ ] you know like like you would and he
looks exactly like he looked in the
photo like with the sunglasses and the
green like the uh fatigue like this
green kind of shirt and everything
and uh so I don't know like like I said
I don't know if she actually did see him
if it was a dream or something like that
so a few weeks later uh she goes to
Dan's mom's house
for Dan's 40th birthday party
so everybody's there they got the cake
and all that other kind of [ __ ] and she
gives him the photo
and he unwraps it and then weirdly and
kind of rudely I thought I don't know if
this is how it really happened but he
like unwraps it looks at it and then
just kind of silently like gives it back
to her
and then just like pretends nothing
happened he's like hey who wants cake
you know what I mean like it was very
very awkward and she's sitting there
going what the [ __ ] and then like her
daughter was like videotaping and she's
like what the [ __ ] mom and she's and
she's like having to pretend she's like
oh yeah okay whatever fine you know what
I mean like every like it was a really
awkward moment and they were kind of
like trying to pretend like it didn't
happen
uh so Dan's mom also saw the photo and
she also seemed kind of upset about it
but also wouldn't say anything so it's
just like this big awkward thing
so yeah so Lisa's trying to play it off
and uh Lisa's kind of like well I she's
like I couldn't figure out what the [ __ ]
was wrong because I thought Dan would
really like it and I don't really
understand like why he didn't and he
wouldn't say anything about it you know
what I mean which like I said seems a
little rude you'd think that he would
what the [ __ ] what the hell
running off like a damn hole
oh
[Laughter]
she remembered something
yeah I gotta do something out of the
room it's an emergency yeah but yeah so
I don't know I just kind of thought that
even if it was awkward you'd at least in
front of other people you would pretend
oh great and then like later on you know
you could maybe take somebody aside and
say like hey I don't really want this
you know what I mean but like in front
of everybody that just seemed really
rude I don't know if that's how it
really worked
so later that night evidently
so the girls like knock on Lisa's
bedroom door like at night and you can
see their breath like you can see
everybody's breath so the girls complain
it's like man it's like freezing cold in
the hallway and Lisa's like oh it's all
it's always cold in the hallway because
there's no heating vent in here or
something like that but the kids are
just like no we're not really buying
that there's like some weird Chicken
around this [ __ ] hallway it's like
way colder than usual so they're asking
Mom it's like hey just leave the light
on in the room we're freaked out
so one of the daughters I think it was
Sarah
um she said that both her and her sister
Laura were like terrified around this
time but that their mom wouldn't talk to
them about it and like pretended like
nothing was going on
now I don't know if this was the same
night but Lisa was apparently awakened
by someone very forcefully knocking on
her bedroom door and it was this was
actually like a pretty good scene too
because it was like you know knocking on
the door but there was no because you
know when somebody knocks on your door
and like the lights on in the hall like
you can see their the shadow they're
like their feet and stuff and she
couldn't see anybody's Shadows like
she's looking and she's like who the
[ __ ] is that and it was like really
freaky so she starts to get the sense
that Michael is maybe in her house
now the next morning she asked the girls
she's like hey was that you guys like
pounding on my bedroom door but they
said no it wasn't
and so then they go off to school
now a few minutes after that they do
kind of like a little little cheap jump
scare thing where there's more knocking
on the front door this time but it turns
out it's not a ghost it's just Dan who
has come over to finally apologize about
being a douche about the present that
she gave him like in front of everybody
so basically what he said uh was that oh
you know Michael is a really painful
subject in the family
um he was always fighting with them and
there had been this really big argument
where apparently like Michael I don't
know if he just basically told the whole
family to [ __ ] off or whatever but it
was something like that I guess and then
he's like you know [ __ ] you guys I'm out
of here and then he signed up and went
off to Vietnam and Dan is like the last
place the last time we saw him he was
getting on the bus like to go to basic
training and it's like he never even
like wrote to us or called us or
anything like that like we never saw him
ever again and then the last thing we
next thing we heard he was dead you know
what I mean like a year or two later
so um Dan said that his mom was like so
not having it that she can't even watch
movies having anything to do with the
Vietnam War at all because of just how
painful the memories are and they just
refuse to talk about Michael just
because they want to put it behind them
because I don't know what the [ __ ] he
said to them but it must be something
really bad and then the fact that he
died soon afterward they were just kind
of like okay well we're just they're
they're just shutting it off and like
not dealing with it right
and then Dan says that the night after
the birthday party
his mom
had a nightmare that Michael was
knocking on her front door and I was
like ooh very monkey's paw
So Lisa freaks out and she's like holy
[ __ ] I had the same thing happen like he
was knocking on my bedroom door
and she's like maybe Michael is trying
to contact you like in order for you
like to tell you hey maybe you need to
like come to terms with him dying or
whatever it is
um but Dan doesn't really seem to want
to hear all that
and Lisa tries to get him to take the
picture with him like take Michael with
you like she refers to it like it's a
person which is a little weird
um and Dan is just like nah I don't want
it and he's just like Michael's dead bye
you know what I mean so there's that
so at this point
it's a little weird it's a whole weird
situation
So Lisa said she felt compelled to put
the photo up in her own bedroom now she
did admit that she thought this was
weird she was like this was obviously a
dude she didn't even know this was like
her you know her ex-boyfriend's brother
who she'd never met
um but she's like the photo had just
become like such a big part of her life
and she just felt the need to put it
there I was like that's pretty weird
like putting photos of like random dudes
up on your [ __ ] bedroom wall I don't
know
so as time went on
the daughters said that Lisa started
becoming a lot more
distant and a lot more isolated from
them like she seemed like she was
getting depressed and she spent a lot of
time alone in her room so I don't know
if she was like communing with the photo
or what
Lisa also said something very
interesting she said she almost kind of
felt special like Michael was hers I'm
like see that's
don't you think that's weird I thought
that was a little bit yeah yeah that's
pretty weird ghost love it's ghost love
we're gonna do a [ __ ] show on ghost
Love Tonight
watch a movie on ghost love that's right
goes to Mrs Muir we've got me reviewing
it soon yeah that's we're gonna review
that one tomorrow
uh Tom Sexes came with the frame
it came with the frame yeah I remember
that I remember that uh movie that was
The Burbs but uh but yeah so that's what
it was but
um okay with the frame
so later on that night Sarah one of the
daughters she can't sleep and she turns
on there's like she has a little radio
or something like that like next to her
bed
now when she turns the radio on there's
a little staticky and [ __ ] like that but
then she hears apparently a voice that
keeps like very creepily like saying her
name over the radio like while she's
going through the dial like Sarah like
that which I would [ __ ] my pants if that
happened that would be like super scary
so I mean At first she thought maybe
it's just like a weird connection or you
know maybe it was a coincidence or
something like that but apparently the
name got repeated like a bunch of times
and it really started to freak her out
she was like yeah [ __ ] that and like
turned it off you know what I mean so
there was that
so at this point Lisa says the photo
seemed like it was
draining out her energy and filling it
back up with Darkness that's kind of
what she said you know talking about
with this episode yeah there's not a lot
of physical phenomena they're talking
about it's very vague emotional stuff
it's stuff that was subjective hard to
prove a lot of it
so you don't know what you're they're
talking about you know are they making
this up there's no way of knowing yeah I
had to sting and this object in my house
it was draining me it kept making me
feel crazy you know
no how do you you know how do you how do
you quantify yeah how do you quantify
that this person's just nuts or is this
really happening you don't know like I
said they didn't seem like they were
obviously bullshitting but I mean it's
kind of like hard to yeah tell you know
what I mean
I mean maybe they were just maybe they
just perceived things in a particular
way you know what I mean there's not a
lot of real concrete phenomenon in this
yeah I mean there was some which we'll
get to in a bit but you know
so um so yeah so she calls up her sister
Carol like she wants to talk about the
sort of like weird obsessive hold this
photo has on her
Carol said that Lisa was saying crazy
[ __ ] like you know when she was at work
she's like oh I gotta get home and see
what Michael's up to and I'm just like
yeah that's that's crazy [ __ ] right
there
now while they're having this phone
conversation apparently the phone
connection starts going bad whenever
Lisa mentions Michael like it starts
crackling and hissing and then she
starts to think that Michael is doing
that too so like that's very Amityville
Horror I was thinking because remember
like an Amityville Horror where
um where uh where Kathy Lutz was like
calling the priest and the phone kept
going
like every time so I I was kind of
getting that kind of vibe you know what
I mean because and there's some [ __ ]
that happens later in this episode that
was like reminded me of poltergeist as
well which we'll get to in a little bit
but this part like the the whole phone
thing that's very Amityville horrorary
you know what I mean
with the with the phone
so Carol is like trying to talk some
sense into the woman like he's not real
it's just a picture and I'm like well he
was real at some point but he's dead now
so you know what I mean so I guess he's
not real anymore but yeah but Lisa is
kind of she's like no I can feel him in
the house and Carol is like just please
get rid of that [ __ ] picture uh but
Lisa said no way that she wasn't going
to although she can't really articulate
why she wants to keep it
Tom Sykes says I only remember Kathy
Lutz stretching in front of the mirror
yeah right
Margot Kidder that [ __ ] she has like
she has like one white stocking on yeah
she had like one white stocking on which
I was like yeah I can't imagine I can't
count the number of times that I was
gonna go exercise and just put on one
stocking
I don't care just
just a sexy 70s [ __ ] yeah
she was kid she was good personality
especially when she was younger in the
other little horror movie that you
showed me she's funny she was funny I
think my favorite role of hers was Black
Christmas exactly from 1974. she was she
was like the boozy yeah [ __ ] I mean
she was [ __ ] great in that I loved
her she was an alcoholic in real life
though I know that's what happened to
her I know but like it became
unrecognizable but her character in that
movie was so great I would have watched
like a whole movie just about her yeah
just like making sarcastic comments and
being drunk all the time she was just
the Pinnacle of [ __ ] 70s sluttiness
but it's in a positive way she was like
a good [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
we have a fire and everything she's okay
yeah we're going under the stars under
the stars [ __ ] that's right booze and
s'mores yeah don't shave don't shave
that's how they were back there hairy
hairy cute and hairy I remember those
little kids they're natural yeah
everybody was natural
lake clarko look like some [ __ ] out of
[ __ ]
out of the movies it was [ __ ] wild
bad to the [ __ ] late 70s 77. I was a
little kid you know 70 be [ __ ]
teenage girls they were older than me
back in those days just teenage girls
walking around nude nudism and [ __ ] was
going on in public
where it was I'm in California smoking
weed
the [ __ ] Park ranchers selling weed I
can rat them out now those they're all
long gone you can buy great weed from
the park rangers they'd sit down yeah
they probably had the best [ __ ] back
yeah and if you had cute ants like I had
I had cute hats and [ __ ] uh they
would take us all [ __ ] camping and it
would attract all the [ __ ] Park
Rangers and they'd come down to the
[ __ ] uh fire at the campfire at night
[ __ ] give out weed and play guitar
and [ __ ] [ __ ] sing [ __ ] John
Denver songs
drinking wine coolers
in fact we had to make a wine cooler it
was just seven up and [ __ ] Andy Green
Springs wine or [ __ ] we had to be
that's where the [ __ ] bottled wine
cooler came from yeah because everybody
was making it yeah they didn't have them
like just ready yeah ready to drink off
the shelf back yeah we're spoiled for
Tori the choice nowadays you can get
like everything pre-made what's funny is
it you know the 70s is dangerous as it
was we we didn't realize you know
there's serial killers and [ __ ] yeah
they were [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
everywhere but people didn't know it was
kind of an innocent time
you know stories started to come out
what was happening and a lot of that
[ __ ] stopped but
people [ __ ] now oh man [ __ ] how
immoral and decadent it was
oh man 70s 60s probably at least out in
California
it was through their [ __ ] roof but it
was just considered to be normal
it's natural man we're Going Back To
Nature hippie [ __ ] it's like like some
hippies yeah yeah
Tom Sykes said how can anybody sleep
peacefully in a tent knowing what type
of predators lurk at night yeah I don't
know the Bears were nice man
the Bears were nice yeah you [ __ ]
Sequoia except for that what's up except
for that one well they probably were
just kind of they were used to [ __ ]
they were used they were used to getting
fed they knew that people would feed
them and they were like hey hey they're
friendly Bears you know friendly Bears
yeah black Rangers don't feed them and
you'll never get rid of them
yeah they'll be coming around all the
time hello can I please like the ones in
our old neighborhood that would come up
and if you had a refrigerator in your
garage and you left your garage open
they'd go in and open your fridge yeah
you had to keep all the food in the car
couldn't keep any food in the tent and
they both and they all knew that the
food was in the car you could hear them
trying to open car doors yeah he's
trying to get in the car and you people
think that a bear can't open a car door
you're [ __ ] tripping I've seen them
open cars before they're pausing like
videos they're intelligent you come back
to be mud around the car doors they were
trying to open every [ __ ] door
and they can open refrigerators too yeah
you know they knew the food's in there
yeah there'd be like five of them trying
to open the door they locked it
[ __ ] flashlight and then go oh
sorry sorry you know it's what we do
what do we do get out of here I'm a bear
yeah yeah yeah be nice I can't get a job
yeah
[Laughter]
squirrels have come up you give them
triskets and [ __ ] [ __ ] pet the
squirrels then they go back up the trees
that they were used to right around the
campsites they were [ __ ] super used
to humans they thought they were pets
well [ __ ] man where where I went to
college so many people fed the squirrels
on the campus that the squirrels got
super bold like one time I was sitting
on a bench like eating a granola bar and
a squirrel jumped up in my lap and
snatched it right out by hand to wrap
your leg thank you leg you're cooking
you're cooking and they run out you go
when's it gonna be ready they're looking
good way get away and then come on man
they're little tree rats little tree
rats [ __ ]
come up in a camper with you they want
some too yeah they're begging
get out of here
yeah yeah Camp guy said the deer on the
Appalachian Trail will come right up to
you yeah yeah like I said if he's any
animal that's like well I mean why
wouldn't they if they can get fed easy
like that it's a lot easier than like
having to work for people been feeding
them their whole lives yeah so they know
hey look there's those things that give
away food
look at those weird hairless monkeys
yeah they've got all kind of good [ __ ]
yeah let's go up and see what they think
I got sidetracked on this [ __ ] man it's
got to go back to the [ __ ] it's not
about 70s [ __ ]
see well you know what happens [ __ ] I
can't help it
I'm a mere mortal man or either that or
you have add
this isn't a great episode
part of it is that this isn't the great
episode yeah but sometimes those are fun
I think those are fun to like talk about
if you just got to look at it at a in a
particular way
this was like come on for the early yeah
it's a week episode for the early
Seasons but considering how dumb like
some of the later ones were this one
looks like [ __ ] oh yeah Citizen Kane
yeah compared to like season eight
season nine season 10 and [ __ ] Jenny and
I are gonna have to [ __ ] record a
bunch of shorts
because we can monetize shorts now and
we're gonna we got to make commercials
got to get new blood into the show and
you know they're they're kind of like
doing a little Tick Tock video they got
to be sideways so we're gonna come up
with some [ __ ] I'm saying we've got to
dress up and do something
Jenny's cleavage we're gonna get some
Jenny's cleavage on video that'll bring
them all to the [ __ ] Channel
that'll do it get you dancing we're
gonna have you dress you up and you can
[ __ ] like twerk for the camera get
like thousands thousands of people
nobody's twerking anymore I'm just
trying to come up with that that's so
old
it sounds like a grandpa okay whatever
[Laughter]
you can do something you can do the
Lindy Hop or something like that
Tom Sykes says I'd rather see Tom in a
curly wig see there you go I could do
anything we could do
we could do like a drunk wig uh modeling
session like with you with all your dick
you have your emotions you got a whole
bunch of old video of me you could just
[ __ ] clip that out of there and do
that yeah that's true yeah
all right so can I make a greatest hits
of me [ __ ] doing stupid [ __ ] with
wigs I know but well that would take a
while because I have to find them they
may Define them all yeah that's what I
mean it's like we've done hours and
hours and hours like it would take for
it to be like finding needles in a
haystack probably just easier to like do
new [ __ ] so I don't know yeah I've been
neglecting wig play yeah like a wig play
because uh I gotta be feeling it at the
time I haven't been feeling it lately
you know I'm not I'm not why I'm not
fake when I do when I do when I go on a
roll it's real that's the way I'm really
doing it
it's legit
maybe you're maybe you just need new
wigs we're gonna work something out
I'm pissed over my [ __ ] Bane costume
it's not turning out right I gotta
return some [ __ ] yeah but you got like
this is too [ __ ] it's too [ __ ] big
I ordered a [ __ ] medium they sent me
a large it doesn't fit
and then I gotta [ __ ] figure out how
to send that back
they sent me a shipping label but I
gotta [ __ ] print it out or order one
that and it hasn't shown yet
I could probably show it to you you
could probably print it out on that
thing right there yeah and have a UPS
come and pick it up we got UPS service
huh well that you will the the post
office will come pick it up oh well you
just leave it on the porch okay
you know what I mean
I've never I've never had UPS pick some
stuff up but I have the post office pick
stuff up from the porch all the time
I guess I got to put in some kind of bag
here a box or some [ __ ] yeah we probably
got boxes someplace yeah
um all right so where was I we got
distracted by it yeah
[ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah Tom Sykes said damn
you Kathy Lutz yeah that's what that's
what happened he got sidetracked by
thinking about hairy [ __ ] yeah but um
70s 70s [ __ ] Margo Kidder yeah I was
thinking about her today because I was
um I was writing a script for a video
that I'm gonna film tomorrow about uh
and I was talking about the Amityville
Horror so I was actually thinking about
Margaret Kidder earlier today she was
cute yeah I thought I thought she was
cute yeah
um so yeah
so uh so yeah she doesn't want to get
rid of the picture because uh she
doesn't really know why because she's
like weird obsessed with it so one night
a bit later I don't know how long later
both the girls wake up
it actually see an apparition of Michael
standing in their room
now at first they're like the girls are
sleeping and then just like smoke comes
in like and you know like cigarette
smoke because he's standing there like
uh smoking a cigarette and looking just
like he did in the photo with the
sunglasses and everything and he's kind
of like standing by the window so he's
like backlit by the Moonlight or
whatever
so they apparently did both actually see
him standing in the room so that's
something
so Laura the younger one screams bloody
murder as you would uh Lisa comes
running in like what the hell is going
on in here Laura says there's a man in
the room there was a man in the room
but Sarah the older one she steps in and
says no no
um Laura was just having a nightmare now
Sarah at this point she's like we both
knew that it was Michael like that the
ghost but we didn't want to tell their
mom because they said well she was
already so stressed out about it and I
don't know if they just didn't want to
encourage it or whatever but they knew
exactly who that was but they didn't
want to tell their mom so Sarah had seen
it too but she basically just said uh no
she was just having a bad dream or
something
so that weekend
Lisa takes both the girls to stay with
Carol her sister so she can have some
like me time in the house like to have a
break from them I guess
so at this point uh this didn't really
factor into anything so I don't know
really know why they focused on it but
Carol gives her this kind of gold cross
necklace that belonged to their mom and
she's like okay just have a nice
relaxing weekend don't do any Michael
stuff you know what I mean
um I noticed the cross because I think
my grandmother gave me a necklace like
that a long time ago like when I was a
kid and it looked exactly the same like
with a little jewel in the middle it was
just like that but like I said I don't
know why they focus so much on that when
it didn't really factor into it because
a lot of times sometimes if they kind of
introduce it it's like oh here have this
necklace then like later on she'll be
like oh you know what I mean like she'll
use it to like fight the spirit or
whatever but that didn't really like
come into play so I thought that was a
little bit weird this this one was just
a little bit like I said a lot of kind
of
I think one of the reasons that it
wasn't that compelling a story was
because it just didn't have
you know it was just kind of like a lot
of uh uh loose ends you know what I mean
like it didn't really have any kind of
like narrative
thrust or anything and it's just there
was a lot of just little details that
really didn't seem to factor into like
the larger story so I don't really know
uh so yeah so Lisa goes back home now
she hasn't I guess she's hasn't been in
the house alone for more than a year
because the kids are always there
now so she's going to make some tea or
dinner or whatever the [ __ ] and she
opens the cabinet and a can falls out
like not necessarily paranormally but
possibly
and then she said that she smelled
something that smelled kind of like
sulfur
in the kitchen
and then she said she felt like a
crackling type of energy that's what she
called it
and then like the reenactment showed
like a bunch of smoke in the kitchen and
then kind of flashing at the window and
then Michael standing there by the
window like in the kitchen like an
apparition but I don't think she said
she actually saw him
but she seemed to think that he was
really there because she starts yelling
at him to go home
and then she goes into her bedroom and
looks at the picture and realizes well
this is getting [ __ ] up and I really
have to like break his hold over me or
whatever so she takes the photo off the
wall and she puts it out in the garage
she actually thought about destroying it
but she said she couldn't really bring
herself to do that because she thought
that the ghost would get mad and would
like retaliate against her so she make
him goes mad no yeah who knows what they
can do so I guess she just took it out
to the garage or whatever and just like
stuck it out there
in the garage
so she comes back kind of Lights the
little candle on her nightstand or
whatever and then gets ready for bed and
I'm sitting there thinking because I
think of like the stupidest things I'm
always just kind of like she falls
asleep and I'm like I don't think it's a
good idea to leave a candle burning next
to your bed while you're sleeping you
know yeah that's that just seems like a
fire hazard you know so it's like I
don't know it was bothering you know I
used to do it I know but I know people
do it but it's like I don't I don't I
wouldn't like to do that it's just like
to me I was just like what if that
tipped over like what if you know it
would they don't
they don't well I don't it could just
want to make sure that wind isn't
blowing and like blow a drape into it
that's what I'm saying that's all I
would be too worried about it I would I
would just rather not just a slow burn
is nice
back when my Gothic apartment
my Gothic apartment hooking up with
cement [ __ ] [ __ ] girls I'm [ __ ]
boss you might fall asleep you might get
the candles going yeah yeah I mean I've
done it before it's just that I don't
know it's just it bothers me I guess
because it just seems like it's not
super safe
but anyway it's fun though well yeah I
know it's fun I'm just saying
so so yeah so she's laying there she's
kind of like looking at the empty spot
where the picture was
and then once she gets in bed there's
kind of like a breeze and then there's
some smoke coming in the window and then
she sees
like the tree thing okay
so there's like blue light outside the
windows she said she felt what she
described as a rush of cold fear into
her chest that's how she described it
and like I said The Apparition
I don't know if she said she saw this
yet I don't know if they are going by
some description or something but
I couldn't tell what the [ __ ] it was
supposed to be like I said was it
supposed to be a person was it supposed
to be a witch it was very folk horrory I
thought but it didn't look like a person
it kind of looked like because Zach was
like laughing when I said earlier like
what I said it looked like I said it
looked like somebody wrapped up in a
burlap sack with like for like uh you
know bundles of tree branches like stick
it out the side like arms and he's like
knowing this knowing the uh the budget
of the show that's probably what it was
and I'm like yeah that probably was what
it was but I couldn't figure out
I was just confused because I couldn't
figure out what the what were they
trying to convey by that
like I said it seemed like it would be
much easier to just get an actor
and like
I don't know like paint them red or
black or put them in a hood or some [ __ ]
like to make them look evil like why
like I didn't understand like why they
were trying to make it look like a
[ __ ]
wendigo or like I said like something
from mid-summer or something like I
didn't really get it uh because and
especially because she didn't say that
she saw something that looked like that
I don't know it was weird
so I was like thinking oh okay whatever
it's witchy so she obviously knew that
this wasn't Michael like I said I don't
know if she saw it or if she just sensed
that it was something different
so she runs out to the garage and gets
the picture back now she's thinking that
Michael had actually been protecting her
from whatever this other scary [ __ ] was
because you know these
the these stories that are out of
Haunting that where they have a ghost
that's not necessarily like harmful
um you're always good there's always
going to be another ghost behind there
that's like the evil one that's
manipulating or controlling the first
nice ghost because you can't ever just
have like a cool Ghost that you know
does your dishes and is nice to you and
[ __ ] like that there always has to be
like some bad [ __ ] when there was some
[ __ ] happens in these Tales it makes you
wonder what are the chances
an encounter with one ghost is rare
enough
two
what's more likely you got one ghost
that's playing good who's playing two
roles he's the good guy and the bad guy
good ghost bad ghosts
or if there are two ghosts
uh statistically you were saying is more
likely this one ghost
acting good one day and then he acts as
the you know and then he's bad the other
yeah maybe he's just when you're reading
into it you know he's just real Moody
Goes yeah Moody has ghosts
that Moody ass ghost or maybe it's not
the ghost the two it's not the ghost of
of two ghosts it's the ghost of of
something that happened a long time ago
so your interpreted as two ghosts but
it's more like a reoccurring memory a
historic historical like something from
history being replayed you're watching
it like a scene you know and it's
slightly interactive maybe it's that or
maybe it's a ghost of somebody with
multiple personality disorder
the chances there being two ghosts is
always very slim because the chances
there being one ghost is [ __ ] super
slim too close
that's a that's a supremely glowy ghost
it's gross it's a ghost it's Radioactive
[Laughter]
nuclear plant meltdown or something
reminds me my buddy chapino from the
Army [ __ ] he was he was he was
Mexican-American from California and he
couldn't say gloves he said gloves would
it be gloves
gloves yeah gloves yeah you know yeah so
you know don't be an [ __ ] yeah still
friends with him on Facebook he works
for [ __ ] uh
you were so [ __ ] one of the federal
agencies but
we still [ __ ] do the gloves thing
every now and then man you need to
forget your gloves did you with a B
[Laughter]
itch no Bailey said hey all did you guys
see the trailer uh Nicholas Cage's new
movie Renfield I've watched somebody was
talking about that the other day he
plays dracula right he doesn't play
right no it's not Dracula it's another
vampire
oh okay it's a it's a Dracula adjacent
yeah yeah he says his name it's a uh
it's not a it's not Dracula
but
at least according to what was shown in
the trailer it's not Dracula well now
I'm gonna have to go watch it because
somebody yeah Zandy comedy
that's okay yeah it looks it looks okay
yeah I think it'd probably it probably
if I mean Nicholas Cage if Nicholas Cage
is in it and he's cage in the [ __ ] out
oh he's usually he does then yeah he's
always interesting with these kids plays
the vampire and another guy plays his
Redfield
all right
I'm down yeah
what is that what is that gonna be like
on some streaming service or something I
don't know okay well I'll I'll look
after this evidently Prometheus three
going straight to Hulu which is good
because I have and it's directed by
Really Scott I'm produced by Ridley
Scott I think it's directed by somebody
else he but he's involved in it
and he says it's gonna because it's not
a big tent pull movie
the movie is allowed to be what it's
going to be
so I think that's [ __ ] great I hope
they get back to the engineer story uh
it's gonna have alien uh xenomorph type
things in it
but hopefully he and it's it's done
In The Same Spirit as that Predator one
was called prey yeah because it that the
prey did well it did yeah
they're gonna um
Really Scott said this is this is like
it says the this is how all the good
Sci-Fi is going to be from here on out
because you don't need a huge budget so
it doesn't have to be a movie for all
people it can be specialized you know
well I told you that's what I kind of
liked about having this kind of
diffusion of streaming services like
it's kind of a pain if in case there's
like a streaming service you know that
you don't have and you want to see stuff
on it but I kind of feel like it's going
to be good for filmmakers because you
don't have to make something that's like
that makes like 40 billion dollars no
because
Prometheus and Covenant alien Covenant
they didn't have to be huge budget
movies they could have been a lot
smaller movies and had they sticked to
the scripts that they had they'd have
been a lot better and from a Sci-Fi
standpoint
[ __ ] all that alien [ __ ] man [ __ ]
list the xenomorph stuff the original
[ __ ] idea because I I read most of
the script from the original Prometheus
it was great before they [ __ ] it up
but they wanted to make that some kind
of xenomorph movie
it didn't work well like I said they
probably listened too much to like uh
you know they did audience well an
audience polling and stuff and they're
like where are the aliens yeah where's
the aliens
they didn't need any of that [ __ ] they
should have stuck right to the [ __ ]
Ridley Scott's idea basically what
they're talking about was the Anunnaki
you know and nariabu and all the niraboo
and all that it was going to be great
all right so uh so where oh the the
weird burlap witch with the branchy arms
so uh so yeah so Michael's protecting
her from the yeah good ghost bad ghost
like we were saying
or a good ghost bad witch wendigo thing
whatever it was supposed to be
so she goes to pick up her daughters at
Carol's house so Carol
for some weird reason gives her another
picture like another framed picture and
this is just like it looked like a
painting I don't know if what the real
one looked like obviously but it was
like a painting of like some art like
trees like along a path like at a park
or some [ __ ] like that
um and she says oh this is to replace
the Michael picture because you did take
it down right and she's like oh yeah
totally I totally took that Michael
photo down even though obviously she
didn't
um So Lisa gets home and puts this new
painting up in the living room uh hoping
it'll bring some positive energy into
the place I'm just kind of like you guys
are attributing way too much power to
um like a paper print in a frame but you
know
uh yeah and obviously not surprisingly
it's not really working
so Sarah is a daughter she says that her
mom was kind of always depressed around
this time uh Laura was always like
scared of some [ __ ]
um both of the girls were kind of like
terrified of the hallway to their room
because remember how I said earlier that
they said it was like oh it was freezing
cold in there and they said they felt
like somebody was in the hallway all the
time so like when they were going down
the hall to their room to bed they would
like hold hands and like run down there
and then like go in the room real quick
and slam the door and Sarah said when
they were in their room they sensed that
someone was out in the hallway and that
someone was like watching them so they
felt like they were watched all the time
and the daughter said that not the bomb
so you know so maybe there was some
weird [ __ ] going on in the house I'm
just saying that you know a lot of this
is really subjective
so later that night apparently uh Lisa
the mom she thinks she hears some kind
of like Whispering or some [ __ ] like
that like coming from the picture behind
her but she's like just trying to ignore
it like you know shut up back there
whatever
later on though everybody gets woke up
by a noise from the living room like
it's really loud so they go out to see
what it was and the new picture that
Carol gave them is like all busted up on
the floor and it's a significant diff
distance from like where it was hanging
like there was no way it could have just
fallen and ended up where it was like it
looked like it had been pitched like
across the rim you know what I mean
So Lisa tries to play this whole thing
off like oh I guess I didn't hang it
right but Sarah the daughter is just
like come off it Mom it's like we know
Michael did that [ __ ] like there's no
way that it could have just fallen off
the wall because it's like way over
there
So Lisa is like super shocked she's like
how do they how do you guys know about
Michael and that and the daughters at
this point they finally admit well we've
seen him like in our room like remember
that time when we told you that Laura
was having a nightmare about seeing a
man in a room yeah that wasn't a
nightmare we both saw him and he was
standing right there so you know and
like I said at this point Lisa said that
she couldn't see him but the girls could
so I took that to mean that every time
they had showed Lisa seeing Michael
previously in the reenactments that she
hadn't really seen him she was just like
sensing him they do that a lot on this
show though but apparently the girls
could see him but she couldn't see him
So Lisa figures okay it's gotten to a
point now where she has to do something
try to get rid of him hilariously it's
1994 I guess she didn't really know what
to do so she looks in the phone book and
she calls I don't know if she called
like information or she called like some
something that didn't have anything to
do with anything you know what I mean
like they didn't have she basically
calls some information service and is
like hey do you guys have know anybody
that can like you know ghostbust or
whatever
and she's like and then they laughed at
me
um but then they did say oh well we did
we do know somebody can help you she
gets a referral to this woman named Kate
who's with some organization that
supposedly releases Earthbound Spirits
or some [ __ ] like that so they give her
that lady's name
So Lisa and the girls go see this woman
and the weird thing they go to this
house and then there's this other woman
who I guess is like the secretary or the
something and she answers the door and
she's like kind of creepy and then she's
like okay we'll come in here and you the
kids have to stay in here though but you
have to like sit in this other room and
then like they bring out the psychic you
know what I mean which is like or the
whatever the whatever she was
and I don't know I just thought the
whole setup was like kind of funny I
don't know what it was like in real life
so so Lisa goes in there to talk to this
Kate person and Kate comes in the room
and it's very smug and it's like I know
why you're here like I know exactly
what's going on and Lisa said that she
was gonna try and not tell her anything
specifically like to see if she was like
psychic for real or whatever and she
said that the lady was like oh I know
exactly what's going on it's like you
brought Michael with you and she like
looks over like there's somebody over
there by the window and Lisa's like what
the [ __ ] and he's like there's nobody
over there obviously
but so what the what this psychic lady
says
is that Michael is his Spirit or
whatever is tied to the Earth
because of the anger that he still feels
toward his family which he can't let go
of he was apparently drawn to Lisa
because of her positivity which okay I
didn't really see that but whatever
um and her proximity to his family
because like I said it wasn't you know
she wasn't part of his family but she
had been like the girlfriend of the
brother you know I mean for a little
while
my Kate also says that Michael thinks
that Lisa is the light so just like
Carol Ann and Poltergeist that's what I
was saying before because remember how
the phone thing was like Amityville
Horror yeah this is like yeah cause like
all the [ __ ] ghosts in in the
freeling house from Poltergeist thought
Carol Ann was the light so they were all
following her so I think it's the same
situation here
[Laughter]
Tom Sykes says this scene was right out
of ghost yeah yeah I haven't seen that
movie in a long time but yeah yeah the
one with Whoopi Goldberg and Patrick
Swayze and Demi Moore what
that's right ghost what's really stood
out to me was the ghost in the damn
Subway
remember I like that character get off
my train yeah [ __ ] and I was like
yeah that's how I picture a ghost to
actually be wasn't he the one that kind
of trained Patrick Swayze how to
manipulate objects and stuff right I
haven't seen that movie in a long time
right I think I saw it although
unless you knew the show you know for
you new people to show
the closest thing to the movie that I
think is the most accurate
that would line up with paranormal [ __ ]
I've experienced in my life and I would
say yeah that movie that that's probably
like that
would have been Frighteners
it's a comedy it's like Back to the
Future yeah it's like a dark comedy
right one of my favorite movies it's a
good movie if you haven't seen it yet
especially the director it's uh Peter
Jackson in it uh yeah you didn't he
didn't he do uh
um Back to the Future No no Peter
Jackson what else did he do wasn't he
the guy that did like Lord of the Rings
and all that I don't know
but um
has a very Back to the Future kind of
tone to it but dark comedy
um good writing
[ __ ] um what's his name agent dadvers
who was uh yeah Jeffrey Combs Jeffrey
Combs is in it which always makes the
movie a thousand times better yeah it's
got [ __ ] uh Lee Ermey in it is in it
he's the [ __ ] drill sergeant that's
[ __ ] keeping all the ghosts in their
graves he's also a ghost yeah but um
he's a hard ass yes
[ __ ] Michael J fox trying to have an
out of instant Out of Body Experience by
killing himself to save his girlfriend
that's what I saw in that movie seems to
be the system with the out-of-body
experiences and the near that near-death
experiences
that system that's shown in that movie
lines up with my experience that it's
that that's I think it's like that
if there are ghosts
which I've never seen a ghost I've seen
Poltergeist which is not a ghost but if
there are ghosts then they're like
then it's a situation like you're seeing
in Frighteners
makes more sense
that's a good movie like I said I think
I feel like a lot of people haven't seen
it but well we have it don't we I
haven't yeah I thought we I thought you
want to see that you want to see uh the
director's cut the director's cut is
better than the theatrical cut I saw
that [ __ ] in the theater when it came
out by myself I was the only person in
the [ __ ] thing because they bombed at
the theater yeah and I thought a [ __ ]
was a [ __ ] Masterpiece I was because
this [ __ ] movie's great I had a good
time you know and I was like yes people
weren't ready for it I was like yeah
that's it that's it I saw that it's like
that dark comedy is always a hard sell
not so much nowadays
um you know there it's still not like
the biggest genre but I feel like it's
an easier sell nowadays because people
get it more yeah but I kind of feel like
when The Frighteners came out I don't
think people were ready for it because
that was what 90s yeah
and that was Michael J fox is one of his
best roles because it's still him he's
basically kind of like Marty McFly but
it's Marty McFly gone wrong he's had
like a little bit of a scumbag yeah he
said tragedy in his life yeah and he's a
paranormal investigator
but also as Ben says a scam artist a
scam artist yeah wait but he can see
ghosts he could talk to him and make
friends yeah that's not a scam he can
actually like he does he gets ghosts to
[ __ ] frighten people so they call him
and he exercises them and makes money
yeah so he can rebuild his dream house
that he [ __ ] up
the day he and his wife [ __ ] got into
the fight and he wrecked the car and he
kind of felt he was responsible for her
death yes so he's kind of like a dark
Marty McFly who in the end gets redeemed
also there's a serial killer angle too
yeah a big circle it's basically kind of
like a uh
who was the serial killer who thought he
was James Dean
with Stark weather yeah it's kind of
like kind of like yeah that's who it's
based on yeah it's great flick great
flick it's a lot of fun I really yeah I
like dark comedies but like I said they
are kind of A Hard Sell and they were
especially a hard sell back then so I
think that people were expecting it to
just be
a standard comedy
which it is it's funny but it's also
like Darkly funny like it's morbidly
funny and some people don't like that
that movie's aged kind of camera I think
it has changed very well last time I saw
it was maybe three years ago and I loved
it again I still I own it
I watched it like three years ago I was
like man this movie's [ __ ] great
yeah it's always fun yeah we watch it
every few years and it's like always we
reviewed it like a while back yeah
um so yeah what do we get distracted by
okay so yeah um so basically Michael
this ghost is hanging around because he
thinks that Lisa is the light just like
Carolina Poltergeist which like I said
that smacks a little bit of me and like
some of the stuff she was saying earlier
about how this but like um like how she
felt special and like Michael was hers
and stuff I kind of feel like she's
doing the thing where she's kind of like
romanticizing
everybody likes to feel special I get
that but I kind of feel like that's you
know oh I'm the light this ghost like
loves me and won't leave
because I'm so awesome like I get a
little bit of that kind of vibe I mean
maybe I'm being unfair but it just kind
of seemed like that a little bit
so um Kate's basically like okay well if
you want to get rid of the ghost like we
have to uh we'll set up a channeling
session uh so we can tell him to get the
[ __ ] out but we need a couple of days to
do that I don't know why so but they
need a couple of days for Preparation I
suppose
but she asks Lisa are you sure that
you're ready to let go of Michael once
and for all and Lisa is just kind of
like oh I don't know like I said she
kind of likes having him around
so and then there's almost kind of like
they kind of show some like flashback
scenes almost like a like a black and
white kind of like romance kind of [ __ ]
going on like just for a couple seconds
like like the guy from the photograph
like putting his hand under her chin and
things like that so I said all right so
the editors of this like uh
episode they kind of knew what what was
what
so then Lisa says she felt like um what
she described as like a shock sensation
in her chest
and then this part made me laugh like
Kate says Michael is gone
and Lisa's like well [ __ ] that was easy
but then Kate's like no he just went
back to your house
and I don't know why that baby laughed
so hard but I was just kind of like he
just popped in at this other house and
he and then she was like oh my God and
he's like he's gone now wow he's gone oh
no I mean he just went back to your
house that's fine like we still gotta
get rid of him some more ice and stuff
yeah I just thought that was like super
funny the way they like [ __ ] framed
back it's just I don't know why it's so
funny to me to like to think of the
ghost like popping around like different
locations you know what I mean like hey
I'm over here now hey I'm just I'm gonna
go back to your house bye you know what
I mean that's I don't know I just
thought that was really funny so that's
just me
So Lisa and the girls for whatever
reason I guess
I kind of felt like there was a scene
missing here like if you've seen this
you might know what I'm talking about
because it seemed like they jumped right
from oh I felt a thing in my chest and
then like Kate was just like oh yeah the
ghost just went back to your house
but then Lisa and the girls seemed like
they didn't want to go back to their
house because they were too scared
so they all go to Carol's house and
sleep over there but I'm like but
nothing happened at the house that would
it wasn't like they went back to their
house and then like all hell broke loose
and they were like holy [ __ ] we gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here and then they
went to Carol's house because I felt
like there was there was a scene that
should have been there that was like
that because as it was it didn't look
like they went back to the house first
they just went from the psychics house
and he said hey hey Michael went back to
your house and nothing scary happened
and then they just went to Carol's house
like oh my God we're so freaked out and
I'm just like why like nothing happened
I don't know they didn't even go back to
the house but anyway so they stay at
Carol's house and then they come back to
the house the next day and see this is
just reinforcing like why I thought
there should be another scene there and
they bring Carol with them to prove to
her it's like yeah some real scary [ __ ]
is going on in this house and they're
bringing Carol with them so she's to
like prove it to her right and I'm just
like but okay I don't know I don't get
it like nothing nothing scary happened
in there like not you know so Carol is
like well I was kind of like
she's like I was kind of a two minds
about it just like I was kind of hoping
that I would go in there and yeah I
would like see some scary ghostly [ __ ]
because then I would know that my sister
wasn't crazy but then on the other hand
I wasn't really sure that I wanted to
see scary ghosty [ __ ] you know what I
mean but you know I get it she didn't
want her sister to be crazy but you know
so they all go in the house now Carol is
pretty much convinced look all you have
to do is get rid of this goddamn picture
and you'll snap out of this weird
[ __ ] Cloud that you're in that's what
she called it she's like you're in this
weird cloud and she goes into Lisa's
bedroom and she is pretty pissed to see
that the photo of Michael is still there
on Lisa's bedroom wall she's like hey
you told me you took it down you big
[ __ ] liar
now Carol is like at this point you know
her sister was so you know obsessed with
this [ __ ] she's like I just wanted to
see the [ __ ] but I want to set it on
fire I want to put it in a shredder I
just wanted to like [ __ ] destroy the
[ __ ] she's like and she tells uh Lisa
she's like I'm gonna take this picture
outside right now and I'm just gonna
smash into [ __ ] pieces but Lisa wigs
out
don't you ever touch him like she gets
all like that and I'm just like okay and
Lisa's like Michael's not the problem
and she says to Carol you don't even
know him and I'm just like oh Jesus like
if my sister started saying this kind of
stuff to me like about an inanimate
object yeah I think I'd be like [ __ ]
called the men with the butterfly Nets
team
so then they go back out to the kitchen
and Lisa is like oh I'm really sorry
about that like I don't know what came
over me
um the picture just affects me in
strange ways and it's making her act
like a loon you know what I mean
so Carol is like yeah your obsession
with this photo is just like out of
control obviously but Lisa is like no
Michael needs me I'm the only person
that cares about him which like I said
that's like some that's some crazy [ __ ]
to say
now during this conversation
the wine glasses which are kind of
hanging they have like she had like one
of those racks that hangs like
underneath your cabinet thing where like
you hang your wine glasses upside down
like to keep them from getting Dusty you
know what I mean so she had one of those
and while they're having this whole
conversation
the wine glasses kind of start rattling
right and as soon as Carol says you have
to destroy that picture
a bunch of the glasses I think it was
three or four of them like fly off like
and fly across the kitchen and like
smash on the front of the cupboards like
almost hitting them you know what I mean
it was like one after the other it was
like smashed smashed like that
so Carol at this point is like yep I'm
out uh and she pretty much herds both
the girls outside
um and she said you could not have paid
me to go back to that [ __ ] house ever
again which you know can't blame her so
Carol's like I'm taking the girls home
with me because this is [ __ ] right
here like [ __ ] glasses being thrown
around and whatnot uh so she just
basically leaves Lisa alone in the house
like hey sort your [ __ ] out we're we're
leaving so uh yeah I thought that was
like kind of funny too
So Lisa goes back to see Kate the
psychic lady
because I guess they had previously set
up uh the channeling kind of deal
so here's this other woman here the
Channeler and I think this actress has
been on a couple of other episodes too
because she looks kind of familiar
so she's there to encourage Michael to
cross over that's her job so they do the
whole thing like little seancy kind of
[ __ ] where they're holding hands or
whatever
so the Channeler immediately grabs
Lisa's hand really hard and makes like a
really evil face except like the girl
that's playing the Channeler is like
just cute as a button so when she makes
like an evil face it doesn't really look
all that evil I'm just like oh look at
her trying to be mean
with her a little because she
about 19 years old or some [ __ ] and I'm
just like okay nice try
um try to look evil it's it's super cute
but yeah so uh so they're asking her
well who are you
and she says her name is Stephen which
Steven doesn't really seem like an evil
spirit name to me I'm not I can't really
be scared of an evil spirit named Steven
you know what I'm saying
I kind of feel like he needs a name like
asthma door or something well something
with some gravitas you know what I mean
like a demon name Steven
hi I'm Ted the evil spirit yeah I don't
know so this is the fact that he had
just like a normal [ __ ] name I don't
know that was another thing that kind of
made me laugh
so they're like so what's your [ __ ]
deal Stephen the evil spirit
um and
Stephen says through the Channeler uh
that she wants to make Lisa suffer
because well she wants to hurt Lisa
specifically because Lisa with was with
Stephen in another life
and he killed her
I'm like so that wasn't bad enough so
now you got to come back and like
[ __ ] okay whatever
Stephen says that Lisa
brought him here
but then like another Spirit comes in
like possesses the Channeler
and I guess this is Michael and he seems
like much nicer
so like we were talking about before it
always has to be good goes bad ghost
yeah so thanks for a more interesting
story the evil spirit I'm like this is
so complicated so the evil spirit has
apparently been manipulating Michael in
order to torment Lisa so I was like well
couldn't the evil spirit just torment
her directly why does it have to like
have a conduit like through another
ghost this seems like very very complex
I don't know how the spirit world works
I'm just saying that it's like I was
like that seems a little convoluted to
me like if you were that evil it seems
like you could just [ __ ] with people
directly instead of going through a
middleman but you know
so Michael the ghost Michael like I
guess he feels bad he don't want to be
mean to her because she was there for
him when his family wasn't and blah blah
so but I guess this other ghost was like
using him to do I don't know I don't
know it doesn't make any sense to me
so Kate tells Michael well you have to
go into the light
because you know it's your time to go or
whatever so Michael says no Lisa is the
light Kate says nah bro the lights above
you and you gotta go up there
yeah it's it's up there in the
chandelier you got you gotta go up there
that's where that [ __ ] is so um so Kate
then says well Stephen can't hurt Lisa
if Michael crosses over like I said it's
very convoluted
so at this point they said like Lisa
said that the Channeler get a got a real
Serene look on her face and apologizes
apparently being Michael at that point
and then Michael apparently like she
like goes into the light okay so he's
he's gone
um and Lisa said she could feel that he
was gone and that she was really like
sad and heartbroken because like I said
he'd been around all the time and she
kind of got obsessed with him and now
he's not around anymore
so here's another thing that was kind of
left hanging because they said that Lisa
never figured out who the hell Steven
was why they looked like a burlap sack
with Branch arms and who the [ __ ] you
know what other life was involved where
he murdered her apparently I don't
really know so like I said there's this
whole backstory that like they never
even filled in
um but she was saying well hopefully uh
Steven won't be able to do anything to
her now that Michael is gone because
that was like the conduit but like I
said I don't know I don't know why
ghosts need a middleman but okay
so they said the House's energy went
back to normal after that Lisa left the
photo on her wall
until a little while later she graduated
from college and moves out the house and
then at which point she just left it
there like in a closet apparently like
that's what they showed on the show like
she took all her other [ __ ] but then she
just like left it like that ah [ __ ] that
and then like she even brings it out
like the boxes and stuff and then like
her sister's like Michael's not in that
box is he you know what I mean she's
like no no I just left him I left him in
there for like some other [ __ ]
strangers that move into the house to
find kind of like the dybk box that's
what I was saying I was thinking that
look at this box it'll [ __ ] you up man
it's got the Jewish ghost in it so I'm
gonna sell it on eBay I may sell it like
give it to somebody else that's somebody
else's problem yeah maybe that's what
she thought like she just left this
picture there and she's like yeah [ __ ]
you future tenants now you're gonna get
on it as well if you go at any time on
eBay you're gonna or [ __ ] Etsy you're
going to find divic boxes they're
they're they got divot box manufacturing
going on
yeah I don't buy it of course I don't
buy it
but the thing is if you could make a
really cool looking one and you could
come up with a good story yeah that's
what they were doing and yeah and you
had like a well you'd have to have like
a disclaimer on there it's like hey
you're not saying that the shit's really
haunted you're just saying you heard it
was haunted okay like you're not making
any claims because you'll get sued
otherwise because people like hey I
spent 300 on that [ __ ] and it's not
really haunted stuff you know what I
mean but uh but yeah so for a while
there was a thing too like on eBay where
where there was kind of a trend for this
was years and years ago I think it was
like after the divot box thing came out
yeah where people were selling like
ghosts and jars yeah which like I said I
don't know I think eBay kind of cracked
down on that kind of [ __ ] afterward but
for a while you could get away with
selling that kind of stuff because you
couldn't prove that there wasn't one in
there right it's like you know so if you
buy a debit box you're [ __ ] just
buying a work of art
that's what I mean so you'd have to make
if I was gonna make a divot box yeah
you'd have to make it so it was cool
looking enough that people wouldn't be
mad like even if it wasn't haunted like
you would just want it because it was
pretty I'll sell you a [ __ ] gin
bottle get your pretty [ __ ] hand
blown glass bottle from Egypt or
something with some inlay in it and just
say there's a bottle with got a gin in
it maybe yeah don't open it can't prove
it eight yeah it's a bad gin okay
don't open it
yeah it won't fulfill any wishes
so don't open it either that or it'll
pull like a monkey's paw on you where
it'll be like it'll fulfill your wish
but in the worst possible way you know
what I mean well that the thing is those
you'd still have people opening it it's
like and then he said well see it didn't
do it at all so your disclaimer is don't
open it it won't fulfill any of your
wishes it'll just give you bad luck yeah
it'll work against you
then they want to open it and if they do
open he says anything that bad happens
to him you say what was that Jim
shouldn't open a bottle yeah because I
mean bad stuff is going to happen to you
yeah
statistically yeah at some point so it's
like any time that happens like yeah
you're sitting there making wishes and
[ __ ]
you know that's not a kind of gin it is
that's not a wish making [ __ ]
it's the [ __ ] okay
be careful of what narrative you're
selling yeah
Ben says you can't sue because something
is or isn't haunted no way of proving
either way see I kind of feel like
that's why
I don't know like because like I said
this was a while back because I remember
when there was a whole like trend for
div book boxes and ghosts and jars and
stuff haunted houses they try to sell
suit for that in certain States
well if it worked I think there's a
couple of states where you actually do
have to disclose well I'm supposed to be
haunted if it's supposed to be haunted
like but I don't know
um because that's the thing it's like
well how many people have to like how
widespread does the rumor have to be
yeah it is there before you have to
disclose it is there a haunted house
registry where you got to register these
[ __ ] to prove that people say that
it's that's what I mean it's just like
there's no way there's no way of knowing
no I mean the thing about it there's no
way of knowing so it's just kind of like
I can see how it was something concrete
like yeah you have to disclose if
somebody got murdered in the [ __ ] yeah
like that's fair enough but
you know oh everybody thinks this is
haunted I'm like well who's everybody
how many people is that you're right and
when did they start saying this right
after the lawsuit
that too so there's all kinds of shits
that's it Richard Brown said wasn't
there a film about the divot box they
did make one
um I think it was after that after that
yeah it was what the [ __ ] was it called
it wasn't called divot box it had
another name
we saw it because I remember like
several years ago we did an episode that
was called I think it was called reel to
Real Horror this was a long time ago
and I think we talked about four stories
like four horror movies that were based
on true stories and one of them was the
dybic box one which was from which we
saw in Paranormal Witness but then I saw
I think [ __ ] the dude uh Negan from
Walking Dead was in that divot Box movie
wasn't he no maybe yeah maybe yeah but
it wasn't called the divot box I can't
remember what it was called though [ __ ]
man it wasn't it was an alright movie
remember that other movie came out in
the 80s
they had some kind of Jewish monster
inside of damn castle and the Nazis went
in there and got it then Let it Loose
wasn't that was that a divot
what was it called The Citadel no the
what was it
Fortress what was that no the oh [ __ ] I
just read that novel too they could keep
the keep I just I remember liking that
movie The book's amazing I have it you
probably like it
um no it was actually kind of it was
like a vampire okay kinda
it was a Jewish monster of some sort
remember it it was it was definitely
something about a Jewish lore
but I I thought it might have been a
dybic it wouldn't it wasn't a Golem no
it was more like a vampire I don't well
now I don't know about the movie I'm
just talking about the novel because I
just read the novel a few months ago I
was talking about the movie in the novel
which the movie was based on I don't
know how much the movie changed it but
in the novel it was kind of like a
vampire okay and it didn't have a Jewish
slant to the story
because not that I remember in the movie
The keep it was a Jewish thing I mean
maybe it was but I can't really remember
yeah I just mostly remember it was kind
of like a Vampire the Nazis found this
Temple of some sort they didn't know
what it was it had all these damn
yeah and they were trying to Holy
symbols yeah you're like what is this
like weird crosses look kind of like a
cross not more like a t
I made out of gold yeah yeah silver yeah
so they thought oh there's treasure and
like a couple of the Nazis were like
trying to dig in the walls and like yeah
the walls got thicker as you got into it
and they're like it's like what is in
here and then once once they busted
through there it released this and then
the monster started like tearing their
heads yeah and it was some Old Testament
thing it it because it spoke yeah it was
a yeah right and like I said in the book
it was pretty much straight up a vampire
okay in the book it was vampire all
right this is pretty much a vampire was
what it was okay in the movie from when
I remember it was like it was it was
like an Old Testament Hebrew
dang like a divot
and it went after the Nazis it [ __ ]
them up well the Nazis they were around
it not all the Nazis but not yeah
because they were out they were out
there like guarding it yeah it was yeah
they were guarding it they didn't know
what it was Ben said there was an old
Jewish Professor yeah there was like an
old Jewish professor and his daughter
yeah and they were like they were
studying it and then there was a guy
that came that was like
like a Van Helsing type character as
well
I haven't seen the movie in a long time
the novel's pretty good though it was a
well-made movie and I think Tangerine
Dream did the [ __ ] soundtrack to it
if I remember correctly they did a lot
of soundtracks yeah back in the day
thinking about it I got to see it again
that Ian McKellen was in it was he
really I forgot about that
sir Ian it's a movie you should see if
you're if you're Jewish and you've never
seen the Keep you should see it it's
it's a it's definitely uh the movie was
right out it was right out at some
Jewish lore
I just don't know the lore I'd have to
go back and and research it may have
been invented only for that movie but it
was some Old Testament stuff it was
pretty cool
yeah Richard Brown said it was directed
by Michael Mann oh yeah that's right
I've been wanting to see the movie and
because I haven't seen the movie in a
long time but I'm about to keep right
but but yeah but I just read the book
not too long ago but I don't know how
different the movie is from the book
because I haven't seen the movie in a
million years Tom Sykes says in
anthology film about a Serial item
cursor would be cool to see I would
really like to see that too because I
really like the cursed item trope I
really like that's why I always kind of
like stuff about like cursed movies like
antrum the deadliest film ever made and
uh cigarette burns like the John
Carpenter one and stuff like that I like
stuff like that so I like cursed movies
I like cursed books I like all that kind
of stuff so yeah I would totally watch a
[ __ ] Anthology like that and Tom
Sykes said somebody purposely leaving
cursed items in the public to find yeah
see that would be a great wrap around
I'm surprised nobody's done that
actually
Tom Sykes also says in an episode of The
Sopranos Tony Soprano turns into a
Jewish Jewish Golem monster he does
he's [ __ ] swinging from my nuts he's
[ __ ] oh okay SG says the divot Box
movie with Jeffrey Morgan is called The
Possession okay well that's probably why
I didn't remember the name because it's
very generic I remember it being an okay
movie though I think I saw bits of it
I think we watched it because I'm pretty
sure we did a show about
about it we gotta watch that again
I remember it being okay I don't I don't
think it was all that memorable but I
remember it being pretty good
I liked that Paranormal Witness episode
yeah it's a good episode I mean I don't
think it was I don't think the divot box
was really cursed or there was a ghost
in it or nothing like that but it was
like a cool idea anyway you couldn't
trap a ghost from my experience couldn't
trap one
they'll go right through any kind of
material
if you trap something it would be
through some spell I don't really
believe in that well see but that's the
thing we've got to hold it through some
kind of psychic Force but then it would
only be like for as long as you're
[ __ ] doing the
concentration it just you could you
can't trap a soul or a spirit they're
they're too free
that you can't hurt them those are free
yeah even an evil one
well I thought that was the whole thing
of a divot box is that there is a kind
of like spell stuff in there yeah like
keeps them from far as I'm concerned
from what I've seen spells wouldn't stop
anything I've had an out of my
experience but it's a year death
experience but the spell would have been
able to hold me in fiction though yeah
you kind of need if you're just saying
the ghost they could just do whatever
the [ __ ] they want then they don't have
a weakness so it's like you can't defeat
them so you really need to have a thing
where well like I said in the keep where
it had this vampire or whatever it was
they had to have it so it was like
contained until somebody busted it out
you know what I mean yeah because other
than that it would just like go around
and [ __ ] everybody up and kill everybody
on in the world you know what I mean
yeah but I mean from what I've seen when
you're in the spirit form you're not
going to be killing anybody
you probably have the power to you
probably could but then you then they
would end up join joining you in the
spirit world and then you had to put up
with them see so it's not in your best
interest to do it
although some people because yeah
when you're in the spirit world and you
kill somebody they don't vanish they
they arrive now they're here forever
damn it so it's not I didn't think this
through right because they're eternal
and now I gotta put up with your stupid
[ __ ] not over here
where you're now more a lot more
powerful than you were
okay so no it doesn't work now you're
gonna have all kind of like ghost
fisticuffs yeah for the rest of Eternity
yeah and when you're in spirit form you
don't have a lot of Earthly desires or
motivations anymore I think the things
change you're not quite the safest
person anymore
you're a more Primal version of yourself
you're not more advanced you're less
Advanced you're more like a child like
because you know
what makes you an adult is all your
animal instincts and all your
[ __ ] experiences and everything but
all those experiences were attuned to
the material world oh that's useless in
the spirit world
you don't need it
so you're not quite as vicious over
there yeah I would think ghosts would be
pretty chill yeah well that's kind of
why I always see us like I don't really
believe in ghosts necessarily but it's
just kind of like every time I see one
of these haunting episodes that have
like an evil ghost in there I'm just
like why the [ __ ] with the ghost care
it's like why would they hang around
like [ __ ] people up it's like hey I'm
gonna [ __ ] with your [ __ ] just because
this that and the other thing it's like
you know why would they give a [ __ ] they
wouldn't that's what I'm saying
it's like they could go wherever they
wanted they could do whatever they
wanted it's like they could they don't
gotta hang around here closest thing to
an evil spirit I ever I ever kind of saw
during that damn Out of Body Experience
wasn't so much an evil spirit more like
primitive Spirits or primitive Souls
kind of like animals and insects but
they don't mean any harm
or sad sad kind of degenerate
spirits that are like in depression but
they're also in a hallucination they're
they're not fully self-aware
that kind of stuff's out there
so you know what I mean they're not
malicious
it's like a person inside of a nightmare
more like that
Tom Sykes says what kind of info could
you find about this case Jenny anything
not really there wasn't a lot of outside
info about this which is not all that
surprising
um like I said I think I mentioned this
earlier the only thing that I found was
uh a post on a haunted on the a haunting
Facebook group or a haunted Facebook
group from 2011
and all it said was the family in this
episode
um actually lived in an apartment not a
house like they showed in the episode
and that it took place in Vancouver
which like I said they didn't mention on
the show but then when they moved they
moved to Redmond Washington this person
that posted this also said that the two
daughters Laura and Sarah
um pretty openly like shared their story
in various paranormal forms but I
couldn't really find anything because
like I said this
you know this episode is from like
season two so this is like pretty old
right it's 2006 2007. yeah something
like that it's old now so so yeah so I
mean those girls are not teenagers
anymore obviously that's a little while
back so I don't know if they're still
out there talking about it yeah the
first four seasons now people these are
old
yeah yeah that's what I'm saying so you
know I don't know if they're still
around or if they've done anything about
it I don't as far as I could determine
nobody wrote a book about it or anything
like that because some of these you know
people are trying to sell their books
which like I said I'm not [ __ ] on
them for doing that I try to sell books
too but you know all right so uh are you
ready to wrap it up yeah you want a ham
sandwich or something
sure okay all right so uh tomorrow we're
gonna be doing a movie review and the
well I was gonna say the one that won
the poll but it was actually a tie so I
asked Tom to break the tie so the movie
we're going to be talking about we're
going to talk talking about more ghosts
talking about The Ghost and Mrs Muir
from 1947. I think that yeah it really
was yeah great movie yeah and so we're
gonna watch that tonight and we will
talk about that tomorrow which is good
because I haven't seen that since I was
a kid she goes to Mrs Muir it's about
three bucks
yeah I think it's 3.99 you can run it on
YouTube and Amazon Prime it's a black
and white flick you're like why do I
watch a black and it's classic movie
ghost movie
about a woman moving into a [ __ ]
haunted house there's an old sea captain
in there
she makes contact with a ghost and they
kind of [ __ ] start this damn
friendship
it's a good [ __ ] flick take it from
me it's a tear jerker it's got a sad
kind of ending in it but uh are you
gonna warn me some of it someone needs
some tissues yeah are you gonna laugh at
me if I cry no it's okay
[Laughter]
he's gonna laugh at me it's it's a
classic movie classic ghost flick not a
horror movie no more like
tragic
tragic romance kind of yeah yeah it's
good we like that good play uh what's it
called again The Ghost and Mrs Muir
m-u-i-r yeah 1947. now who's who's got
it for uh for uh uh YouTube has it you
can rent it on YouTube you can rent it
on Amazon Prime okay and a couple other
places and I think it's 3.99 wherever
you're right like I looked earlier it's
a chick flick but dudes a geek be into
it too it's it's uh
because the the the ghost is a [ __ ]
sea captain and he's the [ __ ] he's the
[ __ ] see that's how they they see
there's something for everybody if manly
asked Tom yeah endorses the movie oh
yeah yeah yeah
if you're on Trend you watch this movie
you'd be crying at the end oh no see I
would I would need to get I would need
to get video of that yeah I'd be like
[ __ ] sniffling and [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my God see that could have been our
first YouTube short Tom crying at a 1947
ghost movie
I'm gonna I'm gonna try and get him to
cry we'll see what happens all right so
we'll see you guys tomorrow uh for
another movie review Thanks for dropping
by everybody good night